[Musique]
ce que tu peux nous raconter son
histoire
en fait c'est le jour où je décide de
quitter ce fameux connard
on va bien monsieur connard allons
l'appeler mais en plus il est appelé
comme ça pour tout on l'appelle comme ça
c'est d'accord mais que voilà qu'on tue
dix connards dans la rue ce retour ne
sait qui se fait appeler comme ça
d'accord et donc je décide de le quitter
il est minuit je dormais et puis et puis
en fait ça s'est mal passé suite au fait
tu décides de santé
oui c'est énorme mais quand même au
dessus il n'y avait rien n'y avait rien
lu avant aucune violence avant si il ya
une fois une violence jeunes avaient
attrapé par les cheveux
il m'avait plaqué sur le leem a effectué
des claques d'accord et je me la laisser
passer
falciani s'est passé en 10 ans parce que
moi je me dis toujours bon il va
comprendre c'est impossible enfin
pourquoi est ce qui t'a dit après pour
devient non je ne sais pas c'est en me
disant je suis donne une autre chance
donc là il est minuit comme mai à minuit
tu détiens dans ma minutu décide de le
quitter comme ça et donc bon à la
deuxième fois ouais je
non non je ne décide pas comme ça c'est
que le mec il était c'était un pm c'est
un pervers narcissique le mec c'était un
mec qui me manipulait qui était millan
qui était moi je suis tombé dans le
schéma de ce genre de personnage
plusieurs fois parce que j'ai une
personnalité qui est un petit peu
atypique et on pourra développer ça dans
un autre si tu veux mais le mec qui
n'arrive pas à s'exprimer ou je sais pas
et est il que c'est tombé je m'étais
fait opérer des deux pieds j'avais deux
pieds je ne pouvais pas marcher j'étais
vraiment en même temps les deux pieds et
du coup il m'a poussé il m'a mis par
terre et il m'a bastonné par dessus mais
c'était terrifiant quoi terrifiant et tu
étais vraiment vraiment vraiment un
moment je sentais plus tu sais à force
des coups dans la gueule tu sens plus
dire que tu deviens elle choque croyable
ouais incroyable et c'est dans quel état
bah après je suis comme dans les pommes
je sais pas si j'ai perdu conscience
il est c'est-à-dire heatley ce nom et
menez comme ça après j'essaie de me
relever mais je peux pas donc je remplis
et j'attrape le téléphone pour appeler
les flics ils étaient toujours là il
était toujours il était en train de
partir et il me rattrape le téléphone il
le fou dans le dans le poêle à bois le
téléphone il était déchaîné quoi après
vous nous avons voulu renvoyer ou bien
c'est terminé c'est là dans la peau que
vous avez vu vous avez porté plainte
derrière on n'a pas voyagé porté plainte
il a été jugé ça a pris du temps il a
été jugé il a
il a eu deux mille euros de l'amande et
puis évidemment tout le monde est trois
ans avec sursis
j'avais eu des nouvelles depuis enfin
après ouais ouais ouais ouais ce qui
vous met crime et moi je réponds jamais
quoi il m'écrit mexique il ya deux mois
je souhaite à partager cette bonne
nouvelle avec toi j'ai répondu qu'est ce
qu'on en a à [ __ ]
non je réponds même pas bah oui on tue
ton est sorti commente a été traumatisée
par cette force et mon porte en fait je
sous entends la résilience je pense que
je dépasse les trucs que je me dis ouais
je pense que j'apprends de tout tu vois
c'est une épreuve et je me dis ok je je
vivrai plus à quoi
en fait c'est que j'ai besoin d'aller
vraiment fond du truc pour pour meurent
tous ces bienfaits réussi à trop
construire derrière avec les hommes
c'est bien avec évitent ou non pas très
vite j'ai passé pas mal de temps à apa
moi être seule
ouais tu arrivais pas ouais tu pouvais
plus faire confiance aux hommes
ouais mais je redis j'ai re la confiance
ça revient à mais aujourd'hui pas je
vais super bien oui tu le sais bah oui
mais c'est vrai il n'a mis un romane
wallace et que je la donne est ce que
pour les deux c'est la dernière question
je voudrais vous poser jouer la poser à
vous deux est ce que vous trouvez ont
fait assez pour les violences conjugales
à vous nous avez dit voilà 2000 euros 3
ans avec sursis
c'est pas ce qu'on pourrait qu'on fasse
esquisse aimeriez qu'on fasse plus
forcément camille je pense que il faut
écouter vraiment sincèrement souvent
elles vont les femmes qui osent et qui
arrive à aller porter plainte on leur
dit enfin on épand n'est pas sûr on dit
ouais mais c'est bon vous êtes déjà venu
après vous êtes revenu sur votre disque
est le plus qui est le plus grave est
excuses - camille sée qu' il ya beaucoup
de femmes aussi qu'ils disent je vais
pas aller porter plainte parce que j'ai
peur qu'on mette ma parole en doute fois
ci c'est ça
voilà voilà il ya un autre truc c'est
que moi j'ai mis des semaines a porté
plainte oui parce que je suis bête le
mât qui gagnent leur frappés quoi c'est
très con d'ailleurs il faudrait savoir
où il est je suis à vendre
supérieur donc porté plainte j'étais la
bomba non enfin j'ai mis du temps à me
dire ok je m'en fous je le fais quoi
merci à vous deux ses amours et on sera
toujours là avec vous surtout pour des
causes comme celle là il faut aller
encore plus loin